[Music]
jeffrey epstein's consigliere
reputedly his pimp has been arrested and
charged with a number of crimes
including sex
trafficking her name apparently is
pronounced glenn
maxwell spelled jizzlane you know who
she is
according to one of epstein's victims
who spoke with fox maxwell is just as
bad as the billionaire she once served
she is a rapist
um she
um destroyed my
what was supposed to be the best years
of my life she is just as
evil as jeffrey i've epstein as
everybody
has painted him to be miss maxwell was
his business partner in this she
she did this to many girls it was a
hateful
and degrading rate and i was dumped off
in my grandparents yard naked
and was told that i wouldn't come back
alive the next time
another alleged victim told 60 minutes
australia which is excellent by the way
about how maxwell
ensnared young girls his private
sanctuary
an isolated prison known as pedo island
where he would share the girls like pray
with his rich
and powerful friends
we weren't anything important to them at
all we weren't even a human being to
them
we were just another toy to be passed
around and
that's what they did prince andrew
should be panicking at the moment
uh because guilin doesn't really care
about anyone else
but guilin i was in the car with her and
she would ask the driver to stop the car
and she'd dash across to the school or
the park
or wherever she was going and she would
like write down her phone number
for a child a young girl and then i'd
see that child at the house
and she'd say they're auditioning you
know i found a model in the park
and i thought it was really strange
because i did see a couple girls in
braces and i've never seen a model with
braces
well that's disgusting so maxwell has
now been arrested but then of course
jeffrey epstein was arrested too
so how confident can the rest of us be
that maxwell will reveal
what actually happened on pedo island in
other places
who was involved who paid for it with
their foreign governments
how confident can we be that she will
make it to a courtroom
ed gavin is a retired deputy warden for
the new york city department of
correction
the man to answer that question he joins
us tonight ed thanks so much
for coming on are you concerned that
maxwell won't make it to court
i think there are some issues that we
have to contend with when you think
about what happened to jeffrey epstein
he supposedly committed suicide in
prison
i don't think so dr michael baden a
renowned pathologist
examined jeffrey epstein and he
determined that the hyoid bone was
fractured
and that's more consistent with homicide
by strangulation instead of
suicide by hanging and of course the
cameras conveniently weren't working
there
i don't think the feds can handle these
prisoners
such high profile prisoners like maxwell
or epstein if i were william barr
what i would do is i would seek to
obtain a substitute jail order
and i would try to have miss maxwell
placed on rikers island with the new
york city department of correction
i mean the jails are empty right now
because de blasio has police reform and
cuomo has bail reform so everybody's out
in the street so there's plenty of room
at the end on rikers
and then we have an emergency services
unit that could handle her
and i think that's the best thing that
could happen and the reason i say that
is because
the jail that she's currently in the
metropolitan detention center in
brooklyn
is notorious for the sexual abuse of
female inmates
let me give you a couple of examples in
2011 there was a female correction
officer there
she had sex on duty with eight uh eight
employees two of them were superior
officers
she also had sex with two inmates one
was a gang banger and a drug dealer
and the other one killed two and new
york city police detectives
and finally we have a lieutenant and
two correction officers recently who
were convicted of um
you know sexually abusing over over 10
women the lieutenant
was um in charge of the unit
he was um one of his functions was to
teach
the officers about priya which is the
prison rape elimination act can you
imagine the guy that's
supposed to be training officers how to
prevent rape in prisons is actually
raping the inmates
so i don't think that that facility is
capable of
handling it there's just too much that's
gone on there recently
and i don't think any female inmate
should be housed there and another thing
i firmly believe
i don't believe female inmates should be
housed in the same facility
with male inmates it just doesn't make
any sense and we need to change that
right unless you believe there's no
difference between the sexes in which
case
you're a [ __ ] here's what bothers me i
don't think anybody
mourns the death of jeffrey epstein as a
man but what does this say about the
country when a guy can be possibly
murdered in a jail cell it suggests that
a lot of people played along with that
the people who are supposed to be
watching him perhaps
officials at the facility why are
none of them in deep trouble right now
why don't we know the truth i don't
understand
well i'll tell you why because we have
corrupt police officials we have corrupt
officials in the fbi we have corrupt
official officials in the u.s attorney's
office i mean just look at what jeffrey
epstein did
going back 10 15 years ago he paid money
to the palm beach police department
police departments shouldn't be
accepting money from private citizens
when he was what sex offender what sex
offender
gets work released from jail the palm
beach county sheriff's offices
facilitated that
epstein formed a company so that he
could pay deputy sheriffs
to babysit him while he was on work
release now i was a war a deputy warden
for security and programs at a new york
city correctional facility in 2000
and we housed about 400 sex offenders i
i never had
one sex offender that was released on
work release
it's unheard of so then you had the
state's attorney way back when
who didn't even bother to interview the
children or their parents
now as you know tucker now i've been
doing human trafficking investigations
for the last 14 years
in the streets of new york so i know a
lot about that and child protective
services was never notified
the family court was never notified and
social services never had an opportunity
to protect those children so law
enforcement has blown this
from the very beginning and now all of a
sudden 10 years later they arrest
jeffrey epstein at an airport exactly
now all of a sudden they find this clown
up in new hampshire
give me a break the law enforcement
authorities that have handled this
is it's just bizarre i've never heard of
anything like it
i do not trust the people that were
involved in this investigation
right so instead they're crushing local
police departments but nobody is saying
this no i agree
yeah give me your give me your 10
seconds exactly
ed thank you for that thanks for coming
on tonight you spun me up
i appreciate it i certainly did